they came in their thousands to see the
man who's ruled turkey for two decades
and hopes to win another presidential
election on Sunday
but this is a very close race and
erdogan is worried enough to have
resorted to giveaways presents for
children
bread for voters and dramatic pay Rises
for public sector workers
here erdogan actually sang to his
supporters they've loved that but then
came something more familiar berating
the west and claiming his opponents
would ruin turkey
they're up to their necks in lies he
told the rally God willing tomorrow at
The Ballot Box they will wake up from
their dreams
and his supporters
so he's delivering this barnstorming his
messages
don't dream about you they are
terrorists
away from the hubbub of rallies a
meeting of women who run fashion brands
aimed at conservative Muslims meeting
them is the most prominent woman in
erdogan's AK party
she predicts a clear Victory and says
erdogan is misunderstood by the West
is
[Music]
Candace
erwan was criticized for the way he
dealt with February's devastating
earthquake accused of a slow and
inadequate response his popularity has
fallen in the affected areas
but the opposition is focusing more on
the economy and on restoring democracy
and they are growing in confidence
how are you feeling about the election
we are sure we are confident very
confident that we will begin in the
first round in the first round and what
do you think is the first thing turkey
should do with a new government to
re-establish democratic values of this
state
but there is nervousness listen to this
opposition candidate who we met on the
street wary of expressing her thoughts
on the president what are you scared of
being of talk of speaking honestly now
yes yes I am scared because I don't know
what will happen while I speak who I
speak with
who will listen this the election I
don't know so I couldn't say everything
but I think
for 20 years erdogan has overseen this
country and influenced global politics
whatever happens next will have huge
consequences Adam Parson Sky News
Istanbul